qui a dit ça
elle est bonne najat très forte en
langue de bois najat je pense qu'elle en
veut plus que les autres elle est
ambitieuse qui peut encore sauver
françois hollande bon d'abord je vous
invite à lire le livre des questions je
les lui honnêtement c'était même un
compliment mais en tout cas je retiens
je retiendrai surtout le côté très forte
en langue de bois sur le site internet
du journal paris match on est tombés sur
du lourd c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire
on m'a dit que je ressemblais à richard
geere maria une femme politique qui ne
voit absolument aucune ressemblance et
nadine morano l'a twitté ont aucune
ressemblance ans je comprends mieux
pourquoi bayrou se fait des films jir
nous a fait rêver lui cauchemarder je
pense que ce sera un débat plus animé
que le premier donc dans un débat plus
animées faut être plus offensifs par
certains sur son plateau avait fait
aussi la promesse ne jamais se
représenter si jamais été battus ou de
se consacrer entièrement leur ville donc
s'il avait tenu leurs promesses
on sera peut-être moins nombreux sur ce
plateau par si j'écoute bruno si à
chaque fois qu'on est battu on n'a plus
le droit de se présenter je te rappelles
tu as été battu à la présidence de l'ump
ça nous a fait un peu sourire
quelques-uns de mes concurrents et amis
de voir que tout le monde n'était pas à
la même enseigne qu'il y en avait un qui
avait droit du tout pas du tout mais on
s'est dit il y en a qui décidément ne
changeront jamais commence d'abord par
essayer d'être élu tu verras que c'est
très difficile
ensuite je vais vous dire aussi si le
nicolas audi amplement que jacques
chirac et je prévois mitterrand n'ont
pas été battus comme président sortant
ont été battus comme candidat par alain
juppé était ministre du budget quand
j'étais étudiant en 1986 c'était même
très honnêtement si vous aviez 60 ans
est-ce que vous proposiez un seul
standard c'est une hypothèse d'école
je vous remercie de la soulever ne s est
pas d actualité
on voit déjà pas très concentré et là il
est carrément en train de s'amuser avec
sa collègue à sa gauche pendant que
wawrinka est en train de jouer
franchement
m
tout est alors et de jean gachassin mais
voilà je crois surtout que wawrinka qui
a perdu était passablement énervé le
prince albert de monaco se fait rare à
la télévision il ne parle pratiquement
jamais nous l'avons rencontré pour nous
parler de la maison familiale de
philadelphie celle de la princesse grâce
qu'il a acquis la semaine dernière il y
aura des bureaux il y aura peut-être
aussi quelques événements liés à la
fondation de ma mère aux états unis et
donc mais je pense que c'était une
opportunité qu'il ne fallait pas rater
je ne regrette pas sa domination
non je ne suis pas sûr de le refaire
mais je ne regrette pas
l'occasion pour le grenelle de
l'environnement et met sa voix